the real question is do you believe in
some sort of intelligence is living or
might be living near the star system
known as Proxima Centauri B and
providing us with techno signatures the
Proxima B story is a bit frustrating it
never should have been made public the
observations were done in a way that is
problematic in the sense that they did
not have a second simultaneous observing
capability it was actually somebody
else's data looking at something else
the ability to have any kind of
validation confirmation just wasn't
there I like to say that if I'd been
running show at Ohio State you never
would have heard about the wow signal